In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinoxadium for July 2 on which we commemorate our Holy Father
Juvenile, Patriarch of Jerusalem.
Our Holy Father Juvenile having received an excellent education in both Greek and Latin,
retired to a monastery near Jerusalem, where he lived in peace until his election to the throne
of Saint James in the year 422.
Throughout the 36 years of his Episcopate, Juvenile, taking up the arguments of his predecessor,
Saint Cyril, continued to battle unceasingly for the recognition of the independence of his ecclesiastical
sea, not because of its importance in terms of numbers, but as mother of all the churches.
Jerusalem, which had been reduced to a small and unimportant town after its destruction by the Romans,
was at that time ecclesiastically dependent on the metropolitan city of Cessaria and Palestine,
under the jurisdiction of Antioch. Shortly after his consecration in the year 425,
Juvenile began to assert the claims of his sea by consecrating to the Episcopate Peter,
the seressing leader converted by Saint Athemios, and he showed special favor to this great saint
and his Lavra. During the third holy ecumenical council gathered in Ephesus against Nistorius,
where he showed himself to be an ardent defender of the true faith, he sat in second place
after Saint Cyril of Alexandria, since the Archbishop of Constantinople, supported by Archbishop John
of Antioch was the accused, and during Cyril's brief imprisonment, he remained the only leader of the
Orthodox party. After the true faith had been recognized by the emperor and Nistorius deposed,
Saint Juvenile participated in the consecration of Saint Maximian as Archbishop of Constantinople.
In the years which followed, he took an active part in the ecclesiastical life of Palestine,
which, thanks to the considerable gifts of the Empress Evochia,
definitively settling in the Holy Land after the death of Theldosius II,
was embellished with magnificent churches and numerous monasteries.
Remaining faithful to the doctrine of Saint Cyril of Alexandria on the persons of Christ,
Saint Juvenile, unfortunately, let himself be led by deuscarus, Cyril's successor
and participated in the robber council of Ephesus in the year 449, which saw the ignoble condemnation
of Saint Flavian and the rehabilitation of the heretic Utiches. He obtained from the emperor the
recognition of his jurisdiction over the whole of Palestine, Phoenicia and Arabia to the detriment of
the sea of Antioch. This, though, was only for a short time, for as soon as they exceeded to the throne,
Polcarius and Marcian, determinedly, undertook to repeal the pseudo-sinnid of Ephesus and punish those
responsible for it. During the Great and Holy Council of Calcedon, Saint Juvenile, recognizing his
errors, placed himself on the side of Rome and Constantinople, together with all his suffragions,
leaving deuscarus as the only defendant. He gave his approval to the tomb of Saint Leo and
took part in the commission in the Church of Saint Euphemia, which drew up the council's confession
of faith. Regulating the question of the rights of the sea of Jerusalem, the fathers allowed it
jurisdiction over the three metropolitan areas of Palestine, but restored Phoenicia and Arabia
to the sea of Antioch. When he returned to Palestine, however, Saint Juvenile had to endure the violent
opposition of the people and the monks who accused him of having betrayed the cause of the true faith
by confessing with the council to Christ. As soon as he arrived, he was met by a delegation of
monks demanding that he repudiate the council. His refusal led to death threats, which forced
the bishop to return to Constantinople and ask for the emperor's support. The opposition turned
into a real insurrection, accompanied by Arsene, Murder and Pillaging. His opponents proclaimed
that Juvenile had been deposed from office and the leader of the fanatical monks, a certain
Fildosios, occupied the Episcopal throne for 20 months, supported by Empress Eudokia, the majority
of the population and the monks. While the whole of Palestine was in disarray, only the Lava of
Saint Athemios remained a haven of orthodoxy, but Saint Athemios himself, hounded by Fildosios,
was eventually forced to retire to the desert of Ruba. A Juvenile's request, the emperor,
wrote a letter of remonstrance to the monks, explaining that the council had in no way betrayed
the orthodox faith. Shortly afterwards, he published a decree, expelling all the bishops named
by Fildosios. The latter condemned to death, fled, first to Egypt and then to Antioch.
In the summer of 453, Saint Juvenile was reinstalled in his Episcopal Sea through the intervention
of the army. Yet, in spite of the support of the civil authorities, the situation remained
extremely precarious and numerous monks were willing to die rather than be in communion with him.
It was only at the end of three years that the people of Palestine and the monks made their
submission. Following the example of Empress Odokia, who, having appealed to Saint Simeon's
stylites, found herself sent back to the side of the defenders of orthodoxy, Saint Athemios and Saint
Juvenile. The Holy Bishop obtained an amnesty from the emperor for all the rebels who had fled
from Palestine and having succeeded with difficulty in establishing a relative peace, he gave his soul
into God's hands on the 2nd of July in the year 458. Through the prayers of our Holy Father's
O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and save us.